pero no
bienvenidos a la entrevista y al comedor
del primer ministro de irlanda en dublín
nuestro invitado es el líder del único
país de la unión europea en tener una
frontera con reino unido
el primer ministro michael martin
bienvenido a france 24 encantado de
estar aquí
reino unido ya se salió de la unión
europea y las relaciones se han vuelto
cada vez más problemáticas incitando a
lord frost el negociador británico del
break city por supuesto e irlanda está
en medio de esos conflictos el primer
ministro empeorará la situación antes de
mejorar
espero que no y pienso que tenemos
mecanismo para poder crear relaciones
buenas y cordiales entre la unión
europea y reino unido irlanda y gran
bretaña son antiguos vecinos hemos
transformado nuestra relación durante
los últimos 40 o incluso 50 años y
nuestra pertenencia común de la unión
europea ayudó y facilitó el crecimiento
y la transformación de esa relación
así que trabajaremos muy duro después
del bridge para desarrollar un acuerdo
bilateral estructurado con gran bretaña
para facilitar las relaciones actuales
entre gran bretaña e irlanda
pero también creemos con fervor que es
del interés de europa y del reino unido-
que haya un fuerte alineamiento entre la
unión europea y reino unido
compartimos valores comunes en cuanto a
la democracia real y berta de expresión
el cambio climático y muchos otros temas
entonces realmente tiene sentido llevar
esto a una nueva fase post bridge shit
irlanda del norte es la única parte del
reino unido- en haberse quedado en el
mercado único de mercancías de la unión
europea hace unas semanas la comisión de
la unión europea amenazó con aumentar
los controles en la exportación de
vacunas hacer landa del norte a través
de la república irlandesa al hacerlo
desataron una gran disputa diplomática
que ocurrió realmente eso fue un error
de la comisión reconocieron que
cometieron un error han sido honestos y
abiertos en su respuesta cuando me puse
en contacto con la presidenta de la
comisión
úrsula von der layen durante la tarde en
la que se tomó esa decisión una media
hora después de que se hiciera pública
siendo justos la presidenta de la
comisión respondió muy rápido y se
encargó de revertir la decisión de la
comisión eso fue bueno porque creo que
si las personas admiten que se cometió
un error y trabajan rápido por
solucionarlo eso es todo lo que se puede
esperar
en situaciones así pero la comisión
pareció lista para revocar parte del
acuerdo del presi sobre irlanda del
norte sin siquiera prevenir al primer
ministro usted sobre el asunto de la
frontera irlandesa le molestó eso y
podría ocurrir de nuevo me sorprendió no
estábamos del todo satisfechos con eso
pero lo solucionamos con mucha rapidez
tengo una buena relación con la
presidenta de la comisión nos pusimos en
contacto y lo resolvimos pero creo que
el contexto fue muy claro en el contexto
de la vacuna en cuanto al fracaso de
astrazéneca de cumplir su contrato con
la unión europea en cuanto a la cantidad
de vacunas que europa esperaba
creo que se trata más o menos de un
tercio de lo que astrazéneca se había
comprometido a entregar cuánta
responsabilidad tiene el fabricante
inglés astrazéneca en esto
creo que astrazéneca hizo compromisos
con la unión europea y no parece estar
en una posición para poder cumplirlos
debe asumir un grado de responsabilidad
la situación no debería haber escalado
hasta el punto de haber utilizado el
artículo 16 del protocolo la comisión
europea se molestó mucho con nuestra
séneca eso fue muy evidente por las
discusiones y por la disputa pública que
se desató entre astrazéneca la comisión
y claramente nosotros terminamos
involucrados y el protocolo termina
involucrado en ese asunto
ahora implementamos mecanismos y la
comisión misma también lo ha hecho sobre
los temas políticamente sensibles y
acordamos que sería una pausa y se
reflexionar ya antes de tomar acciones
respecto a temas de este tipo además
creo que necesitamos bajar el tono en
cuanto a las vacunas es muy
decepcionante que astrazéneca no haya
estado en una posición para poder
proveer la cantidad de vacunas que todos
estábamos esperando es una reducción
bastante significativa de lo que habían
prometido y con lo que se habían
comprometido entregaran esas vacunas
eso todavía es incierto entiendo que la
comisión todavía no tiene claridad sobre
cómo hará la compañía para compensar ese
déficit en el primer trimestre del año
para los suministros de los estados
miembros europeos y eso ha los
programas de vacunación de varios
estados miembros
si la pandemia las guerras por las
vacunas se está formando una tormenta
que podría convertirse en una guerra
fría nacionalista en europa no espero
que no creo que debemos evitarlo a toda
costa no lo sobre estimaría creo que el
problema con las vacunas está
relacionado también con que la mayor
parte de los estados miembros incluidos
reino unido están pasando por una
tercera ola de la pandemia que ha sido
muy severa tanto en términos de números
como en términos de impacto sobre la
salud y la mortalidad es comprensible
que las personas querían tener acceso a
las vacunas con mucha rapidez y eso ha
dado pie para un aumento de las
tensiones pero otras vacunas están en
camino
esperamos que johnson johnson obtenga
pronto la autorización y eso ayudará
enormemente junto con una mayor cantidad
de facer bayón texto
más cantidad de modernas pero también
otros fabricantes de vacunas que están
progresando con las suyas
alrededor de 4000 personas han fallecido
en irlanda por kobe 19 es un país de
unos 5 millones de habitantes los
irlandeses ven que reino unido está
vacunando con rapidez alrededor del 22
por ciento ha recibido su primera dosis
frente a tan sólo el 5 por ciento de los
irlandeses los partidarios del president
decir que las cosas parecen funcionar
mejor por fuera de la unión europea para
nada el brecht no se trata de las
vacunas eso sería un análisis muy
superficial de la amplitud del precio el
brescia es una decisión disruptiva
aceptamos y respetamos el derecho de los
británicos de tomar esa decisión pero es
disruptiva para la economía es
disruptiva para los empleos debilita el
crecimiento económico a mediano plazo y
en mi opinión fue una mala decisión esa
es mi opinión
aplaudo la comprometida relación del
reino unido con las vacunas y ellos han
tomado decisiones al respecto
que decidieron realizar una autorización
de emergencia a diferencia de la
autorización normal y están sacando la
primera dosis
porque también han tenido un gran
desafío a causa de la nueva variante que
ha sido más contagiosa y se verá
entonces adelantaron la primera dosis
básicamente utilizaron la ley de la
unión europea para adelantarse a la
unión europea sí y la unión europea pudo
haber utilizado esa ley pero aclaremos
de qué se trata esa ley cuál es el
mecanismo es básicamente un
procedimiento de emergencia que por lo
general se utiliza cuando un paciente
necesita un medicamento de manera
urgente para ayudarlo a recuperarse de
una enfermedad severa las vacunas no son
medicamentos para enfermedades severas
las vacunas están ahí para protegernos
de contraer una enfermedad es ahora a
causa de la severidad de la variante es
comprensible que las autoridades adopten
una posición diferente al respecto y que
algunos quieran proceder con más rapidez
que otros la cuarentena en irlanda está
en pie hasta pascua con un gran impacto
sobre la economía
cree que la unión europea debería haber
adoptado un enfoque mejor concertado
para combatir la pandemia creo que el
nivel económico europa lo ha hecho muy
bien la intervención europea es algo sin
precedentes no sólo en cuanto al marco
financiero anual sino en cuanto a la
recuperación y la resiliencia una meta
que se había establecido en julio cuando
europa se unió de manera colectiva
el presidente macrón y la canciller
merkel le dieron el liderazgo a europa y
dijeron debemos hacer algo excepcional
aquí para lidiar con las consecuencias
económicas del comit 19 y creo que eso
fue un gran momento para europa y la
unión europea
apoyamos con mucho entusiasmo su
iniciativa y el trabajo de la comisión a
crear esa facilidad de préstamo ese
fondo de préstamos colectivos para
ayudarle a los países a recuperarse del
cob y también creo que el rol del banco
central europeo ha sido fundamental al
facilitar que los gobiernos soberanos
puedan realizar préstamos con tasas de
interés bajas quienes facilitar las
intervenciones sin precedentes de los
gobiernos en cuanto a las economías en
toda europa
sopo what's nos ha parecido que los
apoyos europeos han sido de gran ayuda y
creo que son mucho más fuertes de lo que
podrían haber sido hace cinco o diez
años hablemos sobre el costo del presi
para irlanda
muchos unionistas que quieren que
irlanda del norte permanezca dentro del
reino unido están muy molestos con la
frontera comercial en el mar irlandés y
están presionando al gobierno municipal
para que se deshaga del protocolo de
irlanda del norte en el acuerdo del
éxito
se implementará ese protocolo está en
riesgo el protocolo y se implementará y
en efecto me reconfortan los comentarios
del secretario michael gov junto con
maros sefcovic afirmando que era en
efectivo el protocolo el betis tiene
apenas dos meses así que los problemas
iniciales son comprensibles y el acuerdo
prevé que la asamblea de irlanda del
norte pueda reflexionar sobre este tema
durante cuatro años y creo que
necesitamos darle una oportunidad para
que funcione debemos bajar el tono
mantener la calma y ser prácticos al
respecto y hacer que el acuerdo funcione
para los ciudadanos de irlanda del norte
y para toda la isla de inclán
el presidente ha reavivado las preguntas
sobre la identidad que el acuerdo de
viernes santo había dejado de lado ser
irlandés ser británico en esta isla sabe
cuándo será posible realizar un
referendo sobre la unidad irlandesa aquí
en el sur en la república
dos cosas al respecto el acuerdo del
viernes santo no dejó de lado la
identidad más bien creó un marco para
respetar las distintas identidades y
para tener una igualdad de consideración
entre distintas tradiciones las de
creencia unionista que quieren seguir
siendo parte del reino unido y las de
una tradición de república nacionalista
que quieren ser parte de la isla unida
lo brillante del acuerdo del viernes
santo fue que existiría esa igualdad de
consideración mientras se seguiría
haciendo el trabajo pragmático en la
isla en términos de salud y educación y
de las luchas cotidianas en la vida de
las personas
no tengo prevista una votación sobre la
frontera durante los próximos años en y
durante lo que resta de este gobierno en
vez de eso he creado una unidad
compartida de la isla dentro de mi
departamento para avanzar con la agenda
de una isla compartida preguntándole a
las personas que viven en la isla de
irlanda más allá de sus preferencias
constitucionales o de su tradición cual
creen que es la mejor manera de
compartir la isla de irlanda juntos en
cuanto a la educación a la salud cómo
podemos lidiar con el cambio climático
en la isla de irlanda
eso es un tema que no respeta fronteras
políticas
ese es mi enfoque se trata del enfoque
de wolf con el padre del republicanismo
irlandés que heredó sus ideas de la
tradición republicana francesa y de la
revolución francesa
esencialmente uniendo a las personas y
creando un propósito de unidad entre las
personas a diferencia de suelo enfocarse
en el territorio
y ese es el espíritu bajo el cual
pretendo proceder en los próximos años
como primer ministro el primer ministro
gracias este es el final de la
entrevista nuestro invitado fue el
primer ministro irlandés michael martin
quede con nosotros en france24
[Música]